ほんじゃあ
始めたそうです
実は僕ですねー
9月の最初に
イギリスに
留学に行っていきます
技術に入ってくるんですけど
まあたぶんちょっと期間は秘密にしておきます
面白いんです
で多分すぐに帰ってこないんであまり公
結構長い滞在になると思うんです
しばらく日本にはいません何でイギリスに行こうと思ったかですかー
なんj 切るしに行こうと思ったんですけど
まあ僕ん英語が好きなんで
英語を学びに行きたいと思いました+やっぱ英語だけじゃなくて外国に行くことで
新しい世界観とかを
つけたいなって思って
行ってきます大学きていろんな人に
外国行ったほうがいいよとか言われたんでー
1回どころかなと思って
いきます
入ってる間も動画ちゃんと出そうと思うんでー
ぜひ皆さんねー
イギリスの動画も
楽しみにしていただきたいまだです9月なんねまだ1か月受けられるんですけど
体調予告です外国に行ってきますまじでん
ビッグになって帰ってくるんだよねー
イギリス行っても
動画ドーガー
見ていただきたいと思います
外国留学はお金がすごいかかるんで大変だったんですよ
手続きとかもようやくここまできたって感じなんだよ
ちょっと3告知だけの動画とかあんまりしたくないんですけど
結局新しいカメラ買ったねー
しますね
綺麗です所
うん
というわけで
1主に行ってきます
ん
ムーディん